in recent years
had become recognized and relied on as a
regional mediator
in 2017 when gcc member states saudi
arabia bahrain and the united arab
emirates along with egypt accused qatar
of supporting what they described as
terrorism
and imposed a land air and sea blockade
it was him who intervened
the kuwaiti emir attempted to broker a
settlement
urged for more dialogue between the gulf
rivals and pushed for reforms to prevent
future disputes
we have discussed the situation in the
country foremost the unfortunate dispute
between our brothers in the gulf region
and our efforts to contain it
was born in kuwait city in 1929 the son
of ahmed al-jaber sabah
who was emir from 1944 to 1950.
for four decades he held the post of
foreign minister
in that time the oil-rich country
experienced huge economic growth
but was also vulnerable to regional
struggles
although kuwait had supported the iraqi
government during the nearly decade-long
war with iran in the 1980s
then president saddam hussein ordered
his forces to invade kuwait in 1990
more than one thousand civilians were
killed and hundreds went missing during
the seven month iraqi occupation
which triggered the first gulf war that
same year
after a u.s led air campaign forced
iraqi troops
out of kuwait sobah was closely involved
in rebuilding his country
and in 2003 he was appointed prime
minister
at the time it was widely expected that
his next role would be that of crown
prince
but in 2006 then emir jabrel ahmed
al-jabbar
his half-brother died a new emir
was sworn in almost immediately concerns
were raised over the state of his health
and sparked what appeared to be a power
struggle within the royal family
after a tense nine-day reign the emir
abdicated
the kuwaiti cabinet swiftly nominated
sabah as the next leader
ending what was seen as a major crisis
in 2015 a suicide bomb exploded in a
packed mosque in the east of kuwait city
killing 26 people
the emir immediately rushed to the
mosque despite security warnings sharing
his sympathy with the people
he witnessed kuwait's so-called golden
years of economic growth
and darker periods of conflict regional
turmoil and political crises
towards the end his well-honed skills in
diplomacy and mediation were
increasingly relied on by
other gulf states a role he appeared to
welcome
and one that will be missed
we have multiple correspondents uh
gauging reaction for us
around the world alan fisher is in
washington assad bakes in tehran our
diplomatic editor james bayes is at the
united nations in new york but first
jamal el-sheil is live for us here on
the newshour here in
doha jamal for anyone just
tuning in to this news just take us
through the events of the past 90
minutes or two hours or so
well earlier uh on in the day peter
there were those initial rumors or
reports
that uh the ailing emir uh had indeed
passed away obviously a lot of people
waiting to uh hear that confirmation and
it was roughly around 90 minutes
or so ago that or maybe just over that's
that kuwait state tv
broke from its usual programming
schedule and started
broadcasting versus from the holy quran
something that is
customary in this part of the world once
a death is about to be uh announced
obviously
even though it was expected at some
point that
uh the emir was uh because he was in
such bad health and because of his
advanced
age it didn't really or it hasn't really
softened the blow so to speak because of
the huge shoes that the
late shaykh sabah filled somebody who
was
not just the leader of one of the gulf
corporation council
states not just a regional player but
somebody who
filled a vacuum when it came for the
need for stability for the need
for reason the need for some sort of
conflict resolution
and in that is where a lot of people
will be remembering
him but also feeling that loss that
announcement by state tv obviously
will be followed over the next three
days by
official mourning by closures of state
institutions and other
government bodies but also an
anticipation to wait and find out
how the succession process in kuwait
will unfold and what it will mean not
just for
the gulf country but also for the
uh wider region in terms of the gulf
cooperation council as well as
the middle east as a whole what's the
the process
of mourning and moving on and
remembering
which must happen in tandem as well i
suppose what's that process going to
going to show us over the coming days
well really with kuwait
it is such a unique country in the
region
and therefore there are a lot of moving
parts that a lot of people will be
uh watching and as you mentioned there
it's about the synchronization
between them but also um ensuring that
they
uh also uh uh uh each each one of them
uh uh is is in in in agreement with the
other in complements the others the word
i'm looking for here and
what you're looking at with regards to
kuwait you have a monarchy
but you also have a functioning
parliament which does
have significant say as to how the
country is
ruled so whilst there is an heir
apparent sheikh noah
al-sabah the brother of the late emir he
is
83 years old and that heir apparent once
he assumes if he is to be
named as the emir after the elders of
the sabbath dynasty
meet that name then has to get approved
by the
national assembly which has in the past
rejected
uh and amir in fact the predecessor of
the late
only lasted for a few days before the
parliament
uh removed him because of health
concerns there so it's not necessarily a
given
just because there is a named uh uh heir
apparent that he will rule albeit
likely that he will but it's not
necessarily a given he then
has to uh announce a error apparent and
that's where the
kind of power plays take place in order
to ensure that he appeases all the
different sections of
that ruling family which has two main
branches in it
uh customary between them they alternate
who is
uh the ruler and who is the air apparent
as you mentioned there that's taking
place whilst there is mourning whilst
there will be
obviously preparations for state
funerals and whilst there is
the role of the parliament that is still
uh to be debated considering that the
kuwaiti parliament is one that is
politically diverse it is made up of
different components of
kuwait's political factions but also
sectarian and
that there is also a significant uh shia
minority in the country
as well all of those are going to play
into uh how this
succession will happen but looking at it
uh
peter there doesn't seem and we saw this
also uh
obviously with the differences but when
we saw the passing of the late sultan
caboose of oman
there doesn't seem to be a departure at
least from that
steady stable approach that has been
synonymous
with kuwaiti politics even by those who
are vying for that position
who may not necessarily have been named
as clear
uh successors to the late sabbah jamal
our correspondent here in doha taking us
through the events of the past two hours
jamal stay close thank
you for the moment uh diplomatic editor
james bayes joins us live from the un
in new york any reaction there yet james
well we still got the un general
assembly taking place and in the general
assembly hall they're still playing out
speeches of leaders
so a lot of ambassadors president
present in the united nations no formal
statement yet from the u.n secretary
general antonio guterres but i've been
speaking to someone who's been speaking
to him
since this news came through he's well
aware of the news i was told that the
secretary general always puts out
statements when any
world leader dies saying he's saddened
but in this case he really is very sad
he knew
the emir well remember the
secretary-general has served as
secretary general but before that was
the prime minister of his own country
portugal
and was the high commissioner for
refugees so he knows
the emir very well and is well aware of
what i was told is his
substantial commitment to regional peace
and stability and it was pointed to me
some of the recent things that kuwait
has done
kuwait at the end of last year finished
two years on the un
security council and during that time
they had a key role with regard to the
war in yemen because they were able
to speak to the uae and to saudi arabia
uh because of their close links in the
gulf they were able to pass messages
to iran and they played a key role i
think in the stockholm agreement
which led to at least a part of the
puzzle being fixed not completely fixed
with regard to the port of hodeidah
but of course the efforts at a wider
piece are still something that's eluded
the international
community also kuwait when it's on the
security council took the role
of one of the countries that did the
coordination
on humanitarian affairs with regard to
syria
and i'm told that even now kuwait is
missed because people
valued kuwait's very astute diplomacy
kuwait's ambassador
on the security council kuwait's then
foreign minister that's now its prime
minister and they
very much were following in the
tradition of the emir because
although he was only the emir since 2006
this is a man who's been on the world
stage
for decades he was his country's foreign
minister from 1963
and in fact he was the foreign minister
here at the un
at the ceremony when kuwait joined the
united nations
in 1963 and he was also uh
in um in his role as foreign minister
when the gulf cooperation council
was set up so he is a symbol i think
of continuity and stability in a
troubled region
um that's the big picture let's just get
to one little anecdote that's worth
telling you which is from one of my
colleagues here
at the un bureau for al jazeera one of
our cameramen here
and a few years ago he was asked to go
and film the emir
uh the emir has a property um in new
jersey
and they were asked to go and film uh
the emir me having a meeting there
and when the camera crews and the
photographers turned up they knocked on
the door they were beckoned in and yet
the emir at the top table said no come
and join me
and he let the cameraman and
photographers join him for a meal
so i think a little view i think of the
human side of this man thanks for that
story
james and thanks for your reporting
we'll talk to you in a bit i'm sure live
now to washington
and our correspondent there alan fisher
alan i mean good relations clearly
between
um the royal household in kuwait city
and whoever is sitting
u.s president at least going back to
when i think what iraq invaded kuwait
91-92
that's right but the relationship is
complicated there's been no official
reaction yet
from either the white house the
president or the state department
but the americans will be well aware of
how well the emir was it was an american
military hospital plane that flew him
from kuwait via germany
to minnesota in july that was outfitted
with a complete
medical team an expert medical team now
landing in minnesota you would expect
that
he went to the mayo clinic one of the
world's top hospitals no confirmation
from the hospital that he was there and
since he arrived there in july we know
that he had an operation the day after
he arrived but since then we've had no
update
on his medical condition we don't even
know yet if the emir
was still in hospital and was actually
in minnesota
when he died as i say the relationship
between
kuwait and the united states has been
complicated in recent years
certainly there is a great groundswell
of appreciation towards america
in kuwait that stems back to 1991
and of course that is when there was the
international coalition led by the first
president bush who expelled the iraqis
from kuwait in a war that lasted
just three days and it's perhaps unusual
that on the ground
in one part of the middle east there is
this affection for the americans but
over recent years
things have become slightly more clouded
particularly with donald trump
in the white house there was concern in
the white house
that the emir was building relations
with iran there was concern that
they did not immediately support the
united states when it pulled out of the
iran nuclear deal in the way
that saudi arabia and also israel did
there was concern as well
that the emir was also building bridges
with the chinese too but the
president decided that he was going to
honor the emir and about 10 days ago
here at the white house
there was a ceremony where in his
absence he was awarded
the legion of merit it's one of the
highest honors that can be given
it is presented solely at the discretion
of the president
what is interesting is at that event
donald trump suggested
that kuwait might well be the next
nation to recognize uh
israel in the way that the united arab
emirates and
and others had done so that was
immediately discounted by the kuwaiti
side
well aware of the strength of failing
not just in the national assembly
in kuwait city but also on the ground in
kuwait
itself so although there is this deep
affection there is this
great connection between the two
countries and remember there are
somewhere between
13 and 20 000 american troops based in
kuwait depending on whose numbers you
believe
and the americans still see that very
much as a strategic part of their
their middle east expansion their middle
east efforts um
the expansion is perhaps the wrong word
but their middle east presence is
perhaps
a much better word there has been this
complication
over recent years what will be
interesting now is to see how that
develops first of all
after the election here on november the
4th and of course whoever
is put into the prime position in kuwait
itself
okay alan thank you very much aside big
is live for us in the iranian capital
tehran
i said any reaction there yet
not yet we're still waiting for some
reaction but the amir
did visit iran back in 2014 where he met
president hassan rouhani but also the
supreme leader
to the ali khamenei now the relationship
between iran and kuwait
has been friendly complicated and at
times
somewhat tense going back to the
iran-iraq war kuwait
supported saddam hussein in fact
allowing saddam hussein's forces
to use three kuwaiti islands to stage
attacks against
iran and at the time the president who
is now supreme leader
threatened kuwait if they didn't stop
helping saddam hussein they could become
targets but since then there has been
increased trade there has been
diplomatic relations and kuwait has
tried to play
mediator when the united states pulled
out of
the 2015 nuclear deal well uh kuwait
supported
that deal and has publicly stated
iran's support for iran's right to have
a peaceful nuclear program but again
there have been
tensions in 2011 kuwait accused
iran's revolutionary guards of goods
force that deals with operations outside
the country
that they were carrying out subversive
activity inside
kuwait and in 2015 17 23
kuwaitis were arrested and accused of
espionage
for iran and hezbollah and the iranian
ambassador was
expelled and also after 2017 kuwait put
restrictions on iranian traders but
since then there has been dialogue they
have been talking there is a close
relationship
30 of kuwait's population is shia with
historical
iranian routes and recently as january
when after general qasim sulaimani was
assassinated by the united states
kuwait called in iran's ambassador
denying any
involvement saying that kuwait was not
used by the united states to carry out
that assassination
and recently the iranian ambassador to
kuwait has said that
iran is not seeking to use kuwaiti soil
to target
u.s interests and and he was told by
kuwaiti authorities that kuwait would
not
allow the u.s to use its soil to carry
out attacks against iran so a very
complicated relationship and kuwait has
been walking that tightrope between the
gcc
the united states and iran i said thank
you very much assad big they're
reporting live
from tehran let's bring in marwan
bashara he's al jazeera senior political
analyst he joins us down the line
from paris marwan what will the emea's
legacy how will it be remembered
well you know um i think it will be
remembered along
three lines and that actually might
synthesize or summarize
a lot of what we've heard from our
correspondence today
and i would say they are balance
and they are stability and reform
balance
it was born out of kuwait's suffering uh
from the iraqi invasion in 1990 30 years
ago
kuwait was basically taken over
completely became a government of iraq
until it was liberated
and since then kuwait has threaded a
very
uh fine line between regional
and world power and that's why when you
hear our correspondent from washington
talk about relation with china
well kuwait is a friend of the united
states but it also
became part of the silk road and built a
chinese project when it comes to the
region it also balances out between
uh say iran and saudi arabia within the
gulf itself it refused to take sides
with saudi arabia against qatar so all
in all there's a there's this
legacy of kuwait maintaining balance
between the various powers and and
influences in the region and beyond
the question of stability was also
important because
uh as we've said it suffered a lot and
within kuwait there is an elected
parliament
a rather industrious if you will
uh national assembly that is quite
vocal and quite involved in policymaking
it
legislates and so it works as a balance
with with the ruling family
and hence kuwait is a bit of a unique uh
situation within the gulf region
it it's this the sort of constitution
well it's not exactly the constitutional
monarchy but
this mixed rule if you will uh
uh ensures that both sides
have to maintain certain communication
bridges and
to maintain the stability within the
country and
in the region and third and last the
question of reform is important because
as you know the last 10 years have been
quite
um volatile
in the region since the arab spring
started now to be clear
the emir of qatar was no champion of the
arab revolution or arab spring not at
all
but he would not join the
counter-revolution
trend in the region he would not send
forces he would not
help dictators in the sense of against
their people and in a sense kuwait
itself
has led the way towards reform under the
emir in the sense of
for example women entered the national
assembly they became elected officials
there was a number of reforms within
kuwait of course many
think this still falls short and more is
needed
but clearly there was a clear path
towards reform
in kuwait and that was very important in
the region that is thirsty
for breaking out of of
of the past repression and oppression
and so on so forth
so in a sense reforming it was very
important
and became sort of a middle way between
those who seek revolution
and those who seek counter revolution
okay within that
balancing act marwan he is i think it'd
be fair to say
perceived or he was perceived in many
quarters around the middle east
as being a source of emollience he was
an emollient
influence you've touched on it james
bay's touched on it you know the the
kuwaiti slash omani involvement in the
yemeni peace talks
granted they've stalled a little bit at
the moment compared to where they were
18 20 months ago now but did he carve
that roll out for himself
or was the emir of kuwait always going
to
fulfill that role because of the
not immediate history of kuwait but the
recent history of kuwait
i think that's a good question and i
think both
are important one kuwait as we
just spoke it did go through a lot and
he said to learn
the lessons and it became uh you know
less bold more careful uh
less bullish and and more uh
you know peaceful with itself in the
region trying to build the bridges and
balance
between powers so it was important and
and and that was driven yes uh from from
uh from the kuwait drama of 1990 but
also
uh you know the emir and this is quite
uh you know astounding if you think of
it
he served as foreign minister from 63
to 2003 that's 40 years
of being the top diplomat for the
country
and kuwait was quite ahead of its time
uh
meaning in terms of the gulf countries
it was really way way way up front
and for the kuwait emir to have served
as 40 years of foreign minister
during some volatile times including say
uh you know the oil crisis and you know
the optic embargo
uh the israeli invasion of lebanon the
iraq iran war
the invasion of iraq and all of that of
course you know so
he was foreign minister for some 40
years and he certainly learned the hard
lessons
and became a seasoned diplomat and that
certainly helped him
when he became amir okay marwan many
thanks mawan bashara our senior
political analyst there talking to us
from paris well the crime prince of
kuwait is sheikh nawaz al-ahmad al-jabba
al-sabah he's 83 years old
and is the half-brother of the current
emir now was named the crown prince in
2006 when the emir came to power
the crown prince has been active in the
q80 government for 52 years after
attending university
in the united kingdom sultan barakat is
the director of the center for conflict
and humanitarian studies at the doha
institute sultan
your thoughts at this time please
well obviously this this is a very sad
news
it wasn't entirely unexpected as in the
last couple of months
there has been some new some news coming
out from the united states regarding the
ill health of the emir but nevertheless
it is uh
sad and i think it will it has left the
region
uh worse off
than a few days ago the emir of kuwait
has been recognized for being a unique
diplomat over the last four decades or
so
first when he served as a minister for
an affairs but also recently as an emir
he employed his diplomatic skills in
a very uh special way
across the region and led the mediation
effort in a number of countries
but i think for us uh those of us who
work in the humanitarian sphere
he would be remembered as a humanitarian
leader
and he was in fact recognized by the
united nations as a humanitarian leader
and for many years one of his close
advisers and friends
mr abdullah matu was appointed a special
envoy
for humanitarian affairs to the world
and that was in recognition of the
amazing work that he's done around the
world not just in the arab region in
africa
and latin america and elsewhere through
the kuwait development fund
the many efforts of humanitarian
relief and assistance that he himself
led all of those efforts i think will be
remembered and his uh work will be
missed
relations between different countries in
this region sultan
can be at least complex
stop me if i'm getting this wrong from
what you're saying and from what marwan
was saying to me a little earlier
it seems now that the emir and
his country was quite prepared to and
this was accepted
around the region was quite prepared to
implicitly say to other countries look
we may disagree on that big issue but
when it comes to another
significant issue say a peace process
for yemen we have got to be in exactly
the same place and just because we
disagree
on other issues does not mean to say
that we cannot have
a positive working direction for the
good of you
whoever that other country may have been
and for the good of kuwait
yes absolutely i mean he's one of his
qualities i think is the fact that he
was extremely patient
and uh you feel with him that
he's got all the time for any process
that he engages in
in yemen his uh spearheading of the
mediation effort
despite the fact that it did not result
in a breakthrough
he was very very persistent throughout
and he kept his door open
throughout the process until until the
very last minutes
he kept inviting people to come back to
the table in kuwait
he also did the same with the qatari
crisis
he not only took an opposition where he
refused
to uh boycott qatar but immediately
opened his doors and invited all to come
to his tent
so to speak to try and resolve the issue
diplomatically
so i i think this is a quality that
kuwait have had to
develop under his leadership because of
its
recent history the invasion of iraq to
kuwait
uh the fact that he has had to balance
forces like iran on one side and saudi
arabia on the other
for for a long time the amazing way i
think in which he reconciled with iraq
and
ended up from being perceiving you know
great perceiving himself as the victim
of iraq to
hosting the most important donor
conference for iraq and pledging
considerable amount of money for the
reconstruction of iraq
and and many many cases like that and i
think these are
very special qualities that only er
the late amir could could have and
that's why he ended up known as the wise
man of
the region and when it comes to that
reputation and that title
uh that pseudonym i guess the wise man
of the region
when it got front page coverage that the
kuwaitis
and the omanis were driving the yemeni
peace process
almost two years ago now that was when
the revelations came out
i think it'd be fair to say there was a
reaction outside of this region saying
oh the kuwaitis are involved oh the
omanis are involved
but the reality is that the emea
and the royal household their toolbox of
diplomatic skills
was very big because they had been
around that block
of middle eastern diplomacy several
several times
sure i mean unlike uh oman which can be
occasionally accused as being maybe too
close to the houthis
uh having taken a little bit of a
distance from saudi arabia and the
united arab emirates
kuwait managed to keep equal distance
from uh from all
and and that is really one of the uh
reasons why people felt comfortable
going back again and again to
kuwait to try and resolve the issue uh
in yemen and and and that again it's a
quality that he has accumulated as a
result of his many years
working as a diplomat and and and the
respect that he's gained
uh regionally uh having said so i think
there were some internal
uh difficulties that the later year
faced in the last few years
and some would would argue that maybe
uh following the invasion of iran iraq
of iraq
the invasion of kuwait by iraq maybe
there was a missed opportunity when the
reconstruction happened
that the reconstruction focused too much
and maybe too quickly
on restoring the the oil supplies
and i'm giving the basic economics
priority
when there were many other social and
economic issues that should have been
tackled and this is why for many many
years
people would compare kuwait with its
neighbors and see well it's not
really developing as fast as other
capitals
around in the gulf so if you looked at
the infrastructure in
kuwait city has taken a backseat a
little bit
compared to cities like dalha or dubai
or abu dhabi and so on
and that was blamed on the way the
reconstruction strategy was managed in
the aftermath of the invasion
i'm going to interrupt you there for
which i apologize as james bayes was
explaining the un general assembly
is in session in new york you're looking
you know who he is of course that's
antonio guterres
we understand the un secretary general
is offering us his thoughts
on the passing of the emir of kuwait in
some of the most
important humanitarian actions in the
world
millions of people have seen their lives
saved
or their communities
in deep distress because of conflict or
natural disasters
being assisted and protected
and he was always in the first line of
mobilizing the international community
in acts of solidarity with those in it
i want to express to his family
and to the government and people of
kuwait my deepest condolences
now in just four months since prime
minister trudeau prime minister holdness
and i convinced global leaders in may
25 million more people have contracted
kovid 19
and 600 000 more people have died and
we'll peel away from mr guterres
at that point he clearly has taken a
decision to
react to the news arriving in new york
from kuwait from the wider middle east
that the kuwaiti emea has passed away at
the age of 91. our diplomatic editor
james bayes was listening to that james
that's a
a stunning measure of how well the emea
and his country were perceived there
where you are you know the heart of
global diplomacy
for the u.n secretary general to say
millions of people
are alive because of what this man did
because of what his country
contributed to the diplomatic process
yes and just before the bit that you
heard peter
at the very beginning when walking into
the room the secretary general said i
want to make a personal statement i want
to say
how deeply moved i am personally by the
death
of the emir and it was clear from the
secretary general's tone
that this is something that has affected
him as well
i mean he knew the emir very well these
are two figures that have both been on
the global stage
for a long time antonio guterres who's
now moved on to talk about
um development aid at the time of covid
uh
has had other jobs before he was his
prime minister of his own country
portugal
he was the high commissioner for
refugees so he's encountered
the emir over the years and remember if
you look at the secretary general's long
career it's nothing like
the emir of kuwait because before he was
in the emir he had 40 years
as his country's uh foreign minister
um and in fact if you go back to the
history of the un
he was the foreign minister in 1963
when kuwait joined the united nations in
fact there are pictures of him
in new york uh there when the flag the
kuwaiti flag was
flown for the first time at the united
nations
and also when it comes closer to
kuwait's uh
own region the gulf region uh the gulf
cooperation
council which has certainly been tested
in recent years
that was founded in 1981 he was the he
was the foreign minister at the time
then
so uh he is a real symbol i think in a
troubled region
of stability and continuity james
thank you very much james bayes our
diplomatic uh correspondent there at the
united nations let's bring in ali
akbareni he's a researcher at the center
for strategic studies
he joins us from tehran ali akbar durani
welcome
to this special news hour on al jazeera
the relationship between kuwait between
kuwait city and tehran
sometimes complex definitely always
compelling how will you remember
the late emea and how do you think he'll
be remembered in the upper echelons
of tehran
the late emir will be remembered as
a mediator he he was a seasoned diplomat
who played the role of mediator in
regional conflicts
but iran and kuwait have had a very
complicated relationship
during the iran-iraq war
kuwait supported
saddam hussein's army against iran
ira iranians have not have forgiven
but not forgotten what kuwait did
but after saddam hussein turned to iraq
and
invaded kuwait the history changed
for the people of kuwait and its
government and iran uh
iran adopted a position of neutrality
iran uh assisted kuwait uh
to uh in extinguishing the fire at its
oil wells
and iran's position
as well as kuwait suffering
at the hands of saddam hussein changed
the history
for kuwait and that in that moment was
so crucial
in kuwait's history that the kuwaiti
leadership
tried to adopt a new strategy
while in the past kuwait has been
following a strategy of bandwagoning
following the united states at the
international level and saudi arabia at
the original level
kuwait's suffering at the hands of
saddam hussein
taught this country a hard lesson
as of that moment onward kuwait followed
a policy of somehow hedging
diplomacy or a policy of balancing
trying to
uh strike a balance between the regional
powers and and patch up relations with
big neighbors while while maintaining
good relations
with uh with world powers so that uh
that was a big change for kuwait and and
from
that moment onward iran and kuwait have
generally
enjoyed friendly relationship while
there has been many ups and downs in
recent years
those big tectonic events that you're
talking about the iran-iraq war that
lasted seven
eight years i think it was utterly
ferocious the 1990
invasion of iraq into kuwait the
conflict that followed it
which was short and sharp the actual war
was just for four or five days
what's your reading as to how that
changed
who the emir was becoming because
clearly he was a different man in 1990
1991 to the man that we saw
driving the embryonic yemeni peace
process
two years ago 18 months ago then his his
illness his ill health really
accelerated past him but
i'm intrigued to know how that changed
him
and how he reacted to those events
the late emmy was a foreign minister for
uh four decades and he saw
tragic uh events and very
um very bad
developments in his country's history uh
and it was the uh you know the iraqi
invasion and occupation of kuwait that
had the biggest impact
on kuwait's foreign policy and it was uh
the the emir who was foreign minister in
the past
that tried to lead kuwait through the
regional crisis
and the best approach he he found
was to follow a new policy
of of trying to be a balancer
that's why the kuwait has been
a neighbor different from saudi arabia
and the united arab emirates for iran
while the governments in saudi arabia
the united arab emirates and bahrain
have been
very hostile uh towards iran
kuwait has has followed a different
policy it has tried
to walk a fine line and
trying to pacify both uh its
big neighbors iran and saudi arabia
and avoid tensions while trying to be
a mediator trying to calm down the
tensions
in the region that that has been the
role
uh kuwait has been uh playing in recent
years
and now whether this um uh
strategy is going to continue or not
will depend on
on his successor i expect a smooth
transition of power while the new
leaders
who have assumed power in saudi arabia
and the united arab emirates
have brought greater instability and
tensions
in their relations with iran unlike
qatar which has
been friendly towards iran i expect
the transition of power to to be handled
smoothly and be done something like that
of oman
uh so i do not expect uh kuwait
uh to change its foreign policy and i
expect a continuation
with some uh you know minor probably
minor changes
in the short term uh of the same uh
policy the late
may followed okay we'll leave it there
thank you so much for joining us from
tehran ali akbar delaney he was he is a
researcher at the center for strategic
studies let's talk now to giorgio
caffiero he is the ceo of gulf state
analytics a geopolitical risk
consultancy firm focusing on the arabian
peninsula
he joins us from washington dc giorgio
welcome back
uh to the newshour here on al jazeera
would the relationship
between kuwait and washington have been
so positive
had it not come down to the coming
together
of the first george bush as president
and the now late emir of kuwait
hi thank you very much for having me on
your program today i
would like to begin by expressing my
condolences to the people of kuwait
and the entire gulf region who are now
mourning the loss of the kuwaiti emir
you know prior to the crisis of 1990
1991
the u.s and kuwait had a strong
relationship
but there's no doubt that that conflict
did so much
to strengthen ties between washington
and kuwait city and over the past 30
years
the americans and kuwaitis have worked
so hard
together to advance common interests
which the two countries share and kuwait
has definitely
relied on the united states for security
over the past
three decades and also when it came to
so many issues such as fighting the
islamic states
in iraq and syria as well as trying to
push for a resolution to the gcc
crisis united states leadership
uh depended very much on kuwait as an
important
gulf partner i don't know if you can
talk about
this giorgio but i'm interested in what
happens
as they move forward with this twin
track approach almost
of paying all due respect and going
through a period of mourning
for the late emir and what happens
when it comes to the line of succession
next because
i think people outside the region might
think oh well the crown prince
it it's his but then there seems to be
this
this process of meshing together a
quasi-political process
a political process because you've got
politicians
who have to be involved in doing more
than
just rubber stamping a successor
but less than saying no we should
actually
not have that person
i think it's important to keep in mind
that kuwait is a unique country within
the gcc
as it is a semi-democracy
and there are strong institutions
in place which will be very important
throughout
this transition right now
we all understand that the crown prince
the um 83 year old half brother
of the late admir will be
the next emir of kuwait
however as he is quite old we know
that he will not be on the throne
necessarily for a very long time
and the big question has to do with who
will be
the following a mirror there is
quite a bit of speculation there are a
couple of names whom
experts have been um throwing around for
many
years with a little bit of time we might
come closer to having a better idea
of who will be the next amir
after the current crown prince right now
from an outsider's perspective that
would require just a little bit of
speculation
i think though going back to my point
about the institutions in kuwait
given the strength of these institutions
i think the kuwaitis will be able to
move
forward in ways in which they can
maintain
their stability there are always
outsiders who are speculating about some
sort of a succession crisis
but that definitely does not need to
happen that is not an inevitable outcome
the kuwaitis recognize that they have
been blessed
for many years with stability you know
when you're sitting in kuwait
you can look to yemen iraq
syria so many hot spots around the
region
and that really underscores how kuwait
stands out is an oasis of stability
and i think the kuwaiti government and
the kuwaiti society
will be working very hard to preserve
that stability
in the years to come george you're
always good to get your uh
tempered temperate thoughts on a big
story in this region really good to talk
to you again giorgio cafera on this
this thought-provoking day as the region
comes to grips with having lost the emir
of kuwait thank you